well we can go our producers whipped up
a mock tourism ad for chopped then still
known as Chas the newest nation in the
world in Seattle you might remember it
here's a portion of it it's the capitol
hill autonomous zone located within
beautiful downtown Seattle
it's the anarchists utopia you never
knew you needed it's not wild about cops
good news because there are none masked
men with guns we'll keep you safe and
sound throughout your stay check out
these state-of-the-art porta-potties
we'll see you soon
I want to apologize if you found what
you just saw a hateful disgusting if you
were traumatized by watching it
Twitter's very concerned you might be we
posted that fake ad on twitter twitter
flagged it as quote potentially
sensitive content and then they hid it
from view what were they saying they
were saying beware keep your kids from
watching this what's the justification
for warning people that we have no idea
probably that it's edited video of
course they never flag a clip from the
onion of the daily show obviously you
know why meanwhile our half-hour long
response to nationwide black lives
matter riots has a warning now on
YouTube it says this quote the following
content has been identified by the
YouTube community whatever that is as
inappropriate or offensive to some
audiences by offensive they mean that
the left doesn't like it and that is the
new standard and there's only one
response under that standard silence the
person who disagrees with you
that's why censorship is now everywhere
it's where the tech companies started
censoring the president it's why they're
getting more and more aggressive in
silencing you today it's an offensive
content label seeing you know what's
gonna happen
it'll be erased it's digital it's not
hard to erase it will never give in
obviously the left's goal is to make
dissent invisible and therefore
irrelevant meanwhile these same tech
companies make it very easy to for
twelve-year-olds to watch hardcore
pornography they have no problem with
that at all but political views they
disagree with No
gone with the wind too scary tells you
everything about what they care about
and who they are